we are officially back with the Riddler
of real estate and the Messiah of
mortgage fraud Matthew be Cox Matthews
been doing the rounds he's been doing
the podcast rounds he's been hitting all
the major media outlets all the podcast
gurus we just got back from Miami you
did the vlad TV interview right how'd it
go I just I mean it went oh it wasn't
great it wasn't great because I thought
it's not as casual as this and he has
specific questions so you tend to jump
and every time you would say something
he would jump three or four like stories
that I thought what we're going
chronologically those are kind of
interesting stories people are always
shocked by those stories I'm like so I'm
like do I say something do I interrupt
him do I tell him do I tell him hey look
yeah get a little closer yeah really
yeah cuz they always complained say we
were louder than you - they're like
hearing nothing like hearing you oh yeah
let's please live - I can't this is hold
on Matt Cox is gone
hold on mom I'm actually I'm actually on
TV right now can okay yes you can see me
I can see you - is Saleem there okay
cherlene can you go to youtube to the
concrete channel on youtube okay I'm
actually doing a podcast right now can I
call you back what's remember I can
Texas I'm doing a podcast right now can
I call you back you can go to concrete
with a K on YouTube and see right and
she can watch me alright thanks bye bye
mom I love you
well see you later
does she have an iPhone
Shayne how many milligrams are those
gummies you're about to eat I'm 50 deep
right now oh god damn son throw a couple
more in the mix and see how it goes how
many milligrams is that total right
there 30 apiece figure it out [ __ ] white
for earlier so that's actually a buck 20
so your mom's gonna watch the livestream
she's gonna try I mean she's 90 so she I
talked to her already I talked to her
once today and some chill called me
sometimes twice a day
really we face nice that you kept your
relationship with your mom through all
this you didn't disown you for going to
prison every two weeks loves me really
you're really you're really good you're
mama's boy huh that's that's the only
one who's gotta stick with you six years
you think your girls hanging out your
girl's gone mm-hmm you know unless
you've gotten Millie only guys I know
that their wife hangs out for 10 or 15
years away for a lot of money to come
back they're worth like 30 million
dollars and they keep him the house and
they've got kids and they so then they
they stick around they run to seeing you
and everything but she's got to go get a
regular job and has two kids to raise
yeah she's out of there she's done she's
like a listen y'all I ain't see her
calls but we're done yeah
John LeBrons got a good relationship
with his mom as well yeah I see her I've
seen her company it's crazy so a friend
of mine not really a friend he's like an
acquaintance past a friend a friend from
the past just got locked up in Coleman
the same exact place you are in yeah he
calls me and I get the call you're
getting a call from a federal prison
and it's him and he happens to be in the
same exact block as Frank Amadeo the
Emperor of the world the emperor listen
you know what I want to do look I'm
turning Frank's story go ahead finish it
I was just whatever I was setting you up
go ahead no I was gonna say I'm
finishing so the story which is on my
website inside true crime okay so the
story in
it's insanity I'm gonna turn it into a
book like I'm gonna blow it out maybe 70
60 70 thousand words turn it into a book
I've got a couple of amadeo's people to
or two people that were used to work for
him and they're gonna give me a couple
other people so I'm gonna do interviews
with them and blow it out to a whole
book here's what I'm thinking wouldn't
it be cool to do like t-shirts that say
like Frank amedeo for Emperor 2040 or
2024 whenever he gets whatever is
outdated yeah
and you could do all kinds then send him
one yeah and you can even do shirts with
his quotes on it Oh people will die
people will die no anthrax your entire
village you know I mean he's got he's
got a great quotes you could do that and
then you can do a podcast on the yeah
the book and a story and sell the
teacher I've been talking to him via
email he's has the email system at
Coleman and I talked about he wants to
call in and do a call-in podcast that
would be great only thing that sucks you
gotta break it into 10-minute phone
calls
15 minutes you can do 10 if you can talk
for 15 minutes or did they limit it I
think it's now 10 so crazy all those
people in the prison there's like four
people well I've been shipped out of the
prison because they got sick they caught
the virus mmm what what about a ask a
question nope did you have an assistant
who Austin oh what's her name Oh Katie
okay I can't bring Katie around when
you're here man so anyway what I've said
about if you have her called the prison
you got to arrange you can arrange to
have Amedeo put on a telephone and get a
phone call with them for an hour - but
you're gonna have to make the calls and
fill out the paperwork and remember we
talked about this yeah I do but then I
have to actually act like a legit media
company yeah you do have to it's it's
true you are my Laura legit news company
was it has to be like a news station
yeah but it don't matter
buhbuh used to do that [ __ ] that into
the courtroom yeah you just have like a
nice PDF with your logo on it yeah
you're good to go
he'd send in like
you're the perfect person to help us
you've never been on a livestream on
that have you oh yeah he was on Jake
everyone knows my second podcast I'm
Luke James king of the clips helping out
here I'm grateful to be here we have a
whole youtube channel dedicated to
clickbait run by Luke yep serious we
have two people with Fine Arts degrees
at the table stinky stink line 69
running the switching board is also a
proud owner of a fine arts degree see
there's three people how much I gotta
pay to get one what's wrong with just a
normal picture I mean it's not that
interesting
can't you do just like a people who are
on YouTube they need something extra to
push them over the line cuz it really
takes a lot to make that click I mean
it's not even that bad a clickbait
compared to the other show that's on you
too ours are click baits pretty mild
did you see value tainment is always
very very conservative very tame are
they really yes he doesn't do anything
insane Lomond maybe glad I'll give you a
real nice one yeah define me oh yeah
that'll give you ads are always very
thumbnail his are good his are normal
too there's just like the guy that he
never has anybody making some weird face
or catching them going you know see out
I'm afraid to make a face right now
where there's like everyone see one and
first Russian doll or split second I get
pissed off and then I think wait a
minute calm down it's Danny nobody
watches this channel
there's nobody watching this [ __ ] nobody
cares people want to learn how to make
money people want somebody to follow
people want somebody to tell them what
to do
it's like Sri on saying you have to call
this guy and you can talk to him about
real estate you should not take real
estate advice from me yeah I mean that's
not it's just you know I could tell you
how to do it legally but the Buhner the
problem is people want to buy real
estate with no money down and can you do
it sure there are ways to do it and
there are legal ways but you have to
will no money down sure how do you buy
real estate with no money down you
borrow the money you borrow the money
from a hard money guy that gives you all
of the money but you have to build a
relationship with that guy how do you do
that how do I build a relationship if I
don't if I don't start any hard money
lenders you well you first you start
flipping houses you go find a house for
$50,000 that's going to once it's
renovated with twenty five thousand
dollars it's gonna be worth a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars and
they're out there and you find a hard
money guy that will lend you 65% of it's
after market value or you know once it's
repaired and then you basically have you
have your repair money and you have your
down you or and you have the purchase
price okay then he gives you drawls as
you fix up the house but you need to buy
the house first you can fix it up right
no he'll buy the house for you also
he'll buy the house look for simple
numbers let's say you're buying the
house for $40,000 okay this is just I'm
leaving out a bunch of you're buying the
house you found a house for $40,000 I
just said for simple no you want me to
jump to a million no let's do a hundred
grand that's what I'm saying so but so
we like big numbers around here Matt
coughs forty thousand I didn't want to
use things like dealing with so let's
say for the sake of argument eighty and
you find a rundown piece of garbage
house for eighty thousand dollars and
can you find a piece of garbage house
for $80,000 sure you can um so for 80
grand and it needs a bunch of work right
it needs about fifty thousand dollars
worth of work so you bought it for you
go in you go to a hard money guy you say
listen found this house for eighty
thousand dollars but once it's renovated
the appraised value in the area says
it'll be worth two hundred thousand and
he says you know what you're right if
you put fifty thousand into this it will
be worth two hundred thousand okay so
I'm gonna give you a 65 percent loan to
value that's a hot on a based on a
after market value of an appraised value
of 200,000 that's a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars you're buying the house
for 80 mm-hmm so I'm gonna give you the
80 to buy the house he buys the house
he's got a mortgage on it there's fifty
thousand left over right he's giving you
140 130 so there's 50 grand left over he
says I'm gonna hold the $50,000 until
you start fixing it up once you start
fixing it up I'll give you draws so you
go and you fix up you put $20,000 worth
of work into the property you don't have
any money you have to convince the guy
to put on a roof the drywaller and say
look as soon as you're done I will cut
you a check for that money once that's
done you called the hard money lender he
comes out he says you're right you got a
new roof you did the drywall work you
did some paint I'm gonna release $20,000
he gives you $20,000 you pay those guys
back then you go and you do the next
phase of other repairs until you've done
$50,000 with the repairs he continues to
give you drawls now he's released all
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
right then the fort or the hundred
eighty to buy the house plus the 50 yeah
and the repairs
you owe him 130 you sell the house for
200,000 supposedly you make seventy
thousand it never really works like that
there's always something this goes wrong
and you do have to make those payments
on $130,000 loan while this is happening
mm-hmm
but it is possible now you're saying the
other thing is how do I get a drywall
guy to do the drywall and a roofer to do
it yeah you got raids picket well great
you're gonna have you may have to put
some money into it or you have a credit
card or you get somebody to lend you the
money to do that you know so there are
ways to do it
but what lent what hard money guys gonna
lend money to a guy who's never done it
before
so yeah kind of to partner up with some
you have to do a few of them you have to
slowly ease your way into it and before
you know it once you've done four or
five with this hard money lender he'll
get to a point where we'll start lending
you 80 thousand or 80% 90% 100% cuz he
believes in you
right he knows you've always paid you've
always done what you said you were gonna
do so it's possible but it's highly
unlikely and it's certainly gonna take
time and the problem is most people want
a quick fix they want to make money
right well how do I make money right
away well you don't write you know it
just doesn't work like that if it was
[ __ ] easy if there was some guru that
could tell you then kids these days they
want instant gratification
right right I want an instant
gratification yeah I just had to I and I
got instant gratification and then
eventually it caught up with me and then
I had to go to prison you know so yeah
and I've had that happen a lot and I
always think we what are you doing why
would you what do you I just got out of
prison you don't want to take advice I
mean not that I don't have good advice
or anything but I'm not in a position to
give you I've got guys who say I want to
come work for you I can't barely pay my
bills like a lot of people like don't
look at your past but they see like the
way that you're able to talk and the way
that you're able to carry yourself and
they don't look at like the criminal
part of what you did they see like how
you're able to get to that point of it
being criminal and then they're like oh
well if he could do it I could do it and
if I just listen to him then I could be
like him but I'll be smarter about it I
won't get caught yeah that's what I
thought it's an illusion that's the
problem of gurus it's an illusion it's
like you know where they said never meet
your heroes you know because you're not
you're always there's always a letdown
it is false idol what does that word is
a term for that
I think false idols alright yeah what is
Dogma false prophets false prophet
that's what the word is false prophet
yeah believe in yourself it's all you
got to do work hard and be patient
listen to listen to garyvee persistent
bro you gotta listen to garyvee
persistence yes yes great his great all
of course this whole thing is like work
hard keep your bills low and be patient
mm-hmm that's a good advice yeah it may
stop but people want to hear that no
because it's not a quick fix and there's
a pot I wanna hit I don't want to hear
that and I know it's true I mean but
that's what I got to do yeah so you have
to do it just sucks